apparently people really like our
reaction videos some of them not so much
but mainly good good views is the thing
we're cutting back the budget on the
channel do you know why we realize we
can just also after I paid a lot of
money for this I can't afford guests
anymore yeah so it's just me and you
watching a laptop this is feel good by
the way this isn't real what are we
doing on today's show I I need to ask
you a question though first right what
did you have this okay well do you know
what Jeremy from the f2 our competitor
at the Wembley cup got up do this we
just created composed wrote and produced
a song for Halloween from scratch then
shot a music video for it as you do it
yes yes very much
you definitely do of course I do can I
just say we went to New York shot a
really nice video out there I didn't
tweet I directed edited creatively
directed put this all together I then
put things on a timeline you guys let's
watch them once the credit he deserves
Lauren stop hating jess is probably my
second favorite f2 member ready oh he's
got an OD alright you should have
mentioned it how many years is up 65
player need upgrade to the new the new
version CPM is pretty low these days for
keep you ups wow you really did say
you're gonna go hard before this
remember the beginning of Batman The
Dark Knight the guys on the floor and
he's like what's the difference between
you and I anyway I'm not wearing a
hockey mask that's just you ready the
other night really enjoy and a very long
shot of someone opening a car door and
closing a car door ticking it's time
isn't it it's a slow burner as is jazz
[Music]
I'm wondering did they have the London
cleared for this so that they could film
this or did they go and record it at
3:00 a.m. 3:00 a.m. it must have been
three and I know we've got quite a bit
of money you know they've got that 28
days later kind of budget can I just say
a fair player Jeremy just say please by
the way that's not his girlfriend's
voice she didn't sing this that was
Billie she didn't I feel sorry for
Billie right now he's sat at home
probably in a hospital bed he's an
injury-riddled blood and he's second
where's my exec produce missus why would
someone please think of Billie
that's not an answer machine message by
the way that's Jeremy rapping can I just
say now I see why this is a Halloween
[Music]
and everyone says he's just a big pair
of balls yes ready the lifeboats I want
off I have developed an affection for
Jeremy through the one week up and
through chatting to him a couple of
times and I think he's a lovely guy last
week
no that is what I said that is
definitely what I said last week I had a
nice chat with a revised holiday right
now you film this you watch it you keep
it to yourself I find it difficult to be
affectionate in front of camera mm-hmm
so this is an incredible lesson in how
to show affection and look in love on
camera consistently for what must have
been an extend length of time
by cold as well no wonder they've got
their coats on yeah quite sometimes you
know I think Jay Paul thought thought
ahead because he was like I'll take her
on holiday or keep her in the sunshine
but yeah Jessa's working on a timeline
he's got to get this done we're just
gonna nip out the London pack I love the
idea they went out in the streets and
they started got her trying to juggle a
ball but after a while they just went
[__] it we'll just do the loving look so
moving on to you know last week you
showed me the food review of the legend
that is food reviewer I do reviews on
the youtubes so when you took into your
heart surprisingly out of Norway yeah
and now I want to show you someone who
I've taken into my heart right it's a
woman ah why does this not surprise me
so this is a long time ago
but a lot of what she said really
resonated with me really
I love people who sit in their bedroom
and talking to their potato so this is
gonna be great I was actually getting
ready to go out into this big beautiful
world and something run across my mind
that I really wanted to share with
everyone first and foremost the most
annoying thing on this planet is a
nagging controlling control [__]
nagging don't nag me stop [__]
nagging me okay I'm not sure this is
still a reaction video as much as their
personal attack on someone you know but
let's go with it yeah get attention cook
for him there's never a wrong I mean
there are women out there with their
head screwed on lads we just need to
keep look this one yeah you know I mean
they're out there what is this [__] she
is literally saying what women should be
doing to make a man happy
jinan I mean this is she's nailed it
right you nailed it come here let us
talk
stop interrupting right and another
thing that [__] forget to do once
they get a boyfriend and we can still do
you why don't you do that for once yes
like just go to the strip club you still
gonna come back home to you and if he's
[__] around with the [__] you just
flirted with then you're doing something
wrong little imbalance baby knows a [__]
though what women do sometimes when
they're in a relationship is they become
obsessive
and they want in constantly attention
attention attention right what are you
doing where you are why stop mourning
and
again and when he does say you concern
your own life when he does see you then
be nice do you mean sake stick make him
food have a good time and then he's
gonna think the Sun shines out of your
ass cuz you're not like all the other
morning nagging puns that he was used to
what would you do to keep a woman happy
you've got to treat them well I mean be
nice nice thing yeah what do you want
I'm being nice I've been nice have been
nice is what you what you would say is
that what you would say I was being nice
to you another thing go out and like
learn about what he likes like if he
likes to paintball go learn how to
[__] paintball go buy him a new
paintball gun she what she's got a point
there with so many girls and try to have
conversations with them about what
you're a new and in it's just like
crickets
it's taken years for Kevin Richardson to
build up this relationship of trust and
affection a family of 38 who still have
plenty of their wild instinct 38 he
start his own sort of sanctuary and he
raises these from being babies or like
they ignore him as one of the pack right
so they don't view him as a man the
Boomers are lying I want to meet this
guy and have him on the podcast I never
really put that [__] out there but I
really wanted me I do like that I've got
a mitt that I am worried about the day
when one of the lines turns to the other
line and goes what is pause Lovelace
became eight amigos no I mean I mean
like you know I hate Jerry you didn't
there with them look right that makes it
oh haha
that is so sweet you'll be the [__]
one of them's going you got any bread
why Jerry's coming
oh nothing Lyon was for seven hundred
sixty thousand subscribers what he's
doing basically is he's actually like
raising awareness and stuff for like to
help them because obviously [__] keep
shooting these lions but Americans is an
unbreakable bond until later I'd love to
meet this guy I'd love to even do a
documentary on the problem for you is if
you wanted to do a documentary with him
you would
have to do this is the worry I'd have to
get near the Lions yeah and I definitely
would look like a stick yeah I mean I'm
thicker than a Snickers yeah I mean I'm
faster over 10 meters we've established
on a little [__] 30 yeah 30 Brian is
just turning around and going come on
then and be intimidating so I'm making a
loud noise yeah and then I think oh [__]
that is actually a [__] joke and then
you're done they all run away to take me
lying so for a walk Mick what about you
you know he takes the mother for walks
mm-hmm a journalist who were supposed to
be doing something was camped out
[__] Lions got it where he just takes
one of them to go has anyone noticed
anything funny about Kevin in the group
shot he's not behind
Oh this week yeah we are going to be
reacting the more stuff on me second
channel to rajadi clips in the future
they're not always going to be on the
mid shot so subscribe to that the links
in the description below
right so Vic is moving out this admin
house it's a it's the Pasha [__] all
I'll ever being into my life
it's the poshest place that I walked in
and when they squatting hello guys
welcome to a brand new video we have a
little bit of life update it's the
eyebrows they look like caterpillars
fighting he's really growing into a
butterfly isn't he he's really grown
you've gotten much more handsome the
although he's gone it's annoys you soon
the backdrop and all my videos will be
changing and I'll have a new place we
understood that that's what that means
please acknowledge the difference in
this environment for this videos will
remain exactly the same so I hope you
can live with that
if you can't please unsubscribe from Vic
right now you will see a different set
of lights in the background of the same
game I played yesterday
fellow humans the lights that change
colour in the backgrounds will change
colour in the same way just on a
slightly different ball but I will
remain playing the same exact computer
game not be shocked as my environment
changes okay he's panicky because you
know wise younger subscribers frequent
anything change anything they have a
[__] meltdown yes well I've lived
with Josh Simon and jayjay for nearly
five years now that's same as the amount
of ads he's put on this video
I would show gameplay the game and that
would talk over it that what was going
on kind of probably more updating I was
probably getting more updates from my
life back then who's editing your videos
vic cuz they need a kick right of the on
that what was going on kind of probably
more updating that I don't know can you
imagine this being me and channel
content even the sidemen house it was
just a youtuber house I've been wasn't a
thing it does you know what just stunned
me I can't imagine at any point in
history yeah the funny thing is Vic is
watching Vic I'd love it if in five
years time Vic watches this video of him
watching Vic
so when Vic's moving house again which
he seems to find very unusual in 10
years time Vic will then watch Vic
watching Vic watching Vic right and what
you will call his channel is Vic galaxy
because there are many Vic stars I want
now is to Victor watch this video so
then Vic has Vic watching Vic with us
watching goblet I want to react a bit
watching us watching that would be
incredible Vic if you could do this with
the reaction of us reacting to you
reacting to you Stephanie Oh Alice
the chief pleasure officer that mystery
vibe called for young girls to be given
by voters to banish the taboo around
female masturbation I think what we have
in today's society is an inability to
discuss the female aspect of pleasure I
mean that is true how open are we
supposed to be I do often wonder that so
did mom just hopping upstairs I'll be
right back just stop don't forget your
vibrator darlings a good point yeah yeah
dad don't come in right now I'm
masturbating yeah Haitian Eason she's
just upstairs fighting herself off
she'll be down a little while you were
in the living room got a vibrator with
you cool have a go while you're in there
then love in the kitchen straight away
in it right on the on the washboard yet
hasn't washed it yep
you feel creamed that's too far a steam
sorry talk about the men's side of
things when we talk about masturbation
teenage boys springs to mind she thinks
of teenage boys once
I'll be watching the people we're
letting on TV you decide ah
is she trying to shame grown men who
masturbate saying only teenage boys do
it does it matter what this woman thinks
about teenage boys masturbating I'd like
to sit down and have a good chat with
her about masturbation okay well I mean
that's your progress if you tweet her
see what she says masturbation I think
it's like so chary now and everyone
wants a cherry
sorry are you using language which codes
how you need to speak about masturbation
literally she could have just said look
after Lavigne she rubs her [__] until
the gushes forth that is not a comment
to make about a woman like that on TV
what what is your relationship with that
with ghosts as of last weekend I am
engaged to be married to one now you
[__] out do you know all these Luster's
who refuse to go on tinder because
they're too good for it and they'll
still meet a man someday and then one of
a sudden they're 30 years old no one
will [__] touch them this is what's
gonna happen to you you're gonna be
sucked there on this morning talking to
Philip [__] Schofield Morean a ghost
Philip Schofield dressed as a circus
master this is this has actually become
a very serious relationship yeah she
needs psychiatric [__] help she
thinks she's having a relationship with
a ghost mate like seriously higher on
some [__] drugs this should be on
Britain's darkest are you supposed to
take your husband's name no I mean it's
absolutely fine if you want to they've
got a really hard dad whose name is
known in the area and they're like him I
guarantee I've known he's a hard R&T
that's what it is
he's a hard man I'll give another stupid
comment you know my husband's fine with
it the kids are fine with it also though
if you have a [__] surname you can't get
a good one fast enough do you know what
I mean
he's probably got one like you know are
you a [__] or something personally
what is the [__] point in marriage if
I'm gonna get shafted in the [__]
divorce court later on though releasing
a [__] Dewar's take me [__]
surname you get married though with the
intention of ultimately divorcing that
person I think some women do
unfortunately I was watching Rogen's pod
the other day and he was like very the
richest woman on the planet got from
divorce was got it from a divorce how
many men have got their wealth from
getting divorced [__] zero mother for
well now here or no does that tell you
the system's [__] that's the purpose
of marriage Jeremy we are the one we are
the same and whether you take his name
but to keep the old name it's just
showing like me and I don't need anyone
a talent and it's like imagine marrying
someone like that one [__] me you park
on Christ if the man if you've got the
man's name there's some sort of given T
but you think because society's a little
bit weighted towards the men there maybe
the men after society it's weighted
towards women because society used to be
weighted towards men we've tried to
write all those wrongs and in doing so
we've gone too far the other way there's
women who aren't getting quarter of a
million a year to live on because they
got married to some dude twenty years
ago and they don't even have a kid the
world that's not normal so her husband
sitting in the audience turning up to
her trainer and going they're disgusted
because they've lost the chance for the
biggest pumpkin imagine chugging that
look at the biceps on her she must do
some curls think the much in here on top
of you just riding I really don't want
to or even think about you've done what
I can only describe as a great job now
I've seen this happen in real life not
with the eggs but with arms and it was
shocking if you're in the gym la do
weight you can actually handle and don't
drop your knees to the death and hope
that you can push it with your hands as
well oh god this is a big one that's a
big way he's not himself out there
someone's just casually walked all that
they've not even run into him not
all this was come on straight to the
neck
straighten her neck literally if you
could have you have to arch your back
this much do not pick the way oh this is
going straight it was a haircut like
that you should not be lifting his arms
or everything's going everything it's
all gone it's a look at the righteous
he's old oh well does this guy his knees
are tip about much you can barely even
move I'm not sure this guy's supposed to
be doing this I mean look at this face
his face looks like a balance or Sun or
no way oh my favorite news clips of all
time i watch this regularly to make me
happy right ready after the break we're
gonna interview Eric why had Mayer who
climbed the highest mountain in the
world Mount Everest but he's gay
I mean he's gay excuse me he's blind
there's so many let alone said much of
this somebody going I didn't do it
yeah so El Clasico is nowhere near a
response thanks but he's gay I think
we've watched quite a lot yeah can we
can we end on the go food reviewer I do
reviews on the YouTube whole stick of
butter into a pan nice the anticipation
of it coming there we go oh can you
imagine needing that much you never no
one's ever gone what can that even taste
like at this point I don't understand I
just love him so much do you know what I
mean still just going there it is you
know what the thing is with the whole
channel he's got nice little touches
which clearly show he knows a little bit
about cooking stir stir stir and then
he's got a very good just tap tap do you
know what I mean that is the important
bit here watch wait for it wait for he
looks like Russia Oh
it's the finesse yeah he's finesse
finesse is this food with his two sticks
of butter
I designed about the the cinnamon last
time he was like one shake and then
after and then he's he's he's like too
much remember one shake with the top off
so you shake it not makes it the kids
will never cook for and that's the whole
that's the sadness of it I want to start
a campaign to get this kid training and
become a chef I want to fly into UK I
want to make him a chef Gordon Ramsay
can we get one of those [__] [__]
chefs that we've got the trade him on I
would love to just play Gordon Ramsay
this entire channel I think I watch his
[__] head okay doing a good job
okay so this is nice we're actually both
in silence because we couldn't quite
believe what this is going so well
okay now looks a little dirtier that
worries me a little bit now so little
brown how much put on must be in that
[__] sauce this guy's secret
ingredient everything is just butter
baby is not a specific ingredient it's
just more you know I mean what do we put
in now more Wow
okay sliders okay this makes sense take
the top pop it on it when is he even
gonna taste I don't think he's even
gonna get to the tasting oh my god great
there's no taste
you are kidding it's not a cliffhanger
clearly feels himself a little because
his eyebrows go up when he starts the
video do you know no me wait for it I
like it when he's confident that he's
happy I like him the ingredients you
need for the homemade segments is one
stick of butter preferably room to have
a Shabbat melted
written and it made the incorporation
[__] say it it's gotten to you mental
the salt and the flour together okay I
think this go ahead and whisk those
together in a separate bowl right mister
I can just go ahead and whisk those
together in a separate bowl imagine his
mother coming home and I'm to clean up
after he'd being cooking's she must be
[__] so sick of this guy he just goes
I'll shout over it I've never known
someone so casual in a blatant [__]
of a situation I've never known someone
so calm when they're clearly not having
a [__] easy right he's the Homer
Simpson of youtubers it's better it
literally looks like he's signing off a
stool sample the doctors asked for is a
gone then duck this is what I'm saying
I will genuinely have one of these
though yeah this is the best thing he's
ever made yeah it's a success you I have
to say so far this is a buy I like that
that's a happy ending I've got admit I'm
happy with that you've got some more
leave links the things you want us to
watch in the comments below
tweet us all that good [__] check out
the second channel for more these single
video reviews I'm going to do a few of
them as well and if you enjoyed it make
sure you hit that like button and if you
haven't enjoyed it too or forget to
leave a nasty comment which of course we
won't read thanks thanks very much bye
bye say bye